iconic characters off the pressure a
Knight's Tale this is a very long time
ago brian helgeland had found a tape of
me auditioning for another movie and he
went oh I want this guy and so he flew
over and he screen tested me and the
studios went I don't get it
then he wrote A Knight's Tale and he
wrote a character for me and it that
wasn't the lead but was a really great
character and hooked me on tape and he
showed it to the studio and they went I
don't get it so then they put me with
the actress and he said I don't get it
when I'm not making the movie and
because he had had prior form of
actually not making a movie I guess they
then said fine you can let him be in
your picture and that's the true story
of how Brian Helgeland forced me into
the studio system so we were in Prague
just having a ball because we you know I
thought everything was possible and and
I had a grueling really fun cast and it
was everything that you could imagine it
was mayhem Heath was the most alive
person that I've ever met and that's
very puzzling to imagine him
not around I still can't quite picture
him not around somehow because he was
just so alive and all of the nonsense
that I've read subsequently about
darkness and it's just in no way meets
the human being that I knew and fell in
love with everybody fell in love with
Heath he was pretty naturally good at
making you adore him a beautiful mug it
came together again because Brian
Helgeland Ron Howard was looking for an
actor and I've made a movie called
gangster number one and Ron Howard
wanted to see something of me in a movie
where I wasn't playing a psychopath
Brian was cutting his movie in and he
should run some footage of me not being
a psychopath gangster and then I got a
call and I flew out to New York it was
super romantic because it was snowing
and it was amazing and and then I and
when an audition for him and he gave me
the job very old-fashioned way
I don't know how young actors do it
anymore were just soft tapes because you
can go into a room and you can try and
win people over and be charming and make
them want to spend time with you and
you're already halfway to getting the
job before you then badly read the
character in the scene the twist at the
end about my character I absolutely knew
because I read the script in those days
people let you read scripts so I would
be the thoughts of publishing a script
online so yeah I read I knew exactly
what was happening mastering commanded
the fast I didn't work we shot Master
and Commander in a tank in Rosarito
Mexico and it was an amazing time Peter
Weir is a fantastic director and we went
to sea for a couple of weeks but mostly
we shot in that tank it was a really
great experience it's also you know a
great experience
living in Mexico for five months was
amazing I loved Stephen
he's a great character to play he's sort
of the polar opposite of me and that he
is crazy well-educated and got so many
personal resources that you feel he's
one of those people that you feel if if
he was put in solitary confinement for
ten years he would come out pretty much
the way went in having had some really
interesting thoughts about things
whereas I would be a gibbering neurotic
mess The Da Vinci Code again it was Ron
Howard Ron Howard's always putting his
hand out and helping me out he needed
somebody to play a psychopath this time
and I guess he remembered there against
number one thing he's in but we were
friends by that point and he's so lovely
to work for he really understands actors
he gives you so much space to explore
and doesn't rain you in and and then
just comes in and gives you some ideas
about and he's a phenomenal director and
I loved creating that and I had a
brilliant makeup artists called Veronica
McAleer who did my makeup and created
that look kneeling on the floor whipping
myself with a whip was peculiar making
Tom Hanks fart on my first day in a
fight because I punched him in the
stomach and he farted I didn't know what
to do I was like what do you do when
you've made the lead in the movie far
and so I sort of pretended it didn't
happen and he was like what's wrong with
you what's wrong with you some funniest
thing ever
his son he's awesome actually I was
supposed to make that before Master and
Commander and it got delayed because I
really really wanted to go and work with
Peter Weir and they made it okay for me
to do that Peter colt I spent eight
months training to learn to play tennis
because I've never picked up a tennis
racket Pat cash formal Wimbledon champ
taught me how to play tennis I'd never
done a romantic comedy before it's
really difficult it's just really really
it's hard it's hard to be that
relentlessly charming the whole time and
maybe something that another actors
better at than me as I was trying to
sort of channel and carry grounds or
Hugh grew up maybe the problem is my
second name's not grant because they
seemed to have such a deafness of touch
and a sort of unerring accuracy with
delivering that kind of light charming
champagne comedy it is more about John
February thankfully he played my agent
brilliantly yeah it's so brilliant at
improvisation and he's so naughty we
were doing a scene where I'm trying to
sneak it all lying in bed he's keeping
an eye on me and I'm trying to sneak out
to go and see my my girlfriend he rolled
over and asleep and I was just had just
married Jennifer my wife and he rolled
over in her sleeping that night listen
II can hear in the movie he's cheeky I
got a phone call from John Favreau
saying I need the voice of a sort of
personality less robot and I thought of
you immediately so I said yes and then I
ended up doing Jarvis and then that was
a great gig because they just gave me a
bag of money for coming in at the end
and doing what 45 minutes voice work and
it was awesome and when you haven't been
able to tell the story in camera and
whatever CG hasn't worked and then
you've had reshoots to try and explain
this you can just have jarvis go the bad
guys are coming over the mountain and
every and you're done so it was a great
job because everybody was really happy
at me doing very very easy thing and
they gave me money which is which is
always nice people
eventually this big Hollywood producer
told me that my career was over and I
was done in the business and that I
should pop my bangs and sling my hook
and go home and I kind of stood up to
him in the room and said you know what
people have second and third acts in
this town and then but then I went
outside my legs were like jelly and it's
that pound on the on the pavement
sidewalk and I said maybe he's right
maybe my career's over and my my phone
went and I answered my phone I didn't
know the number and I said hello and it
was Joss Whedon and Joss Whedon said you
want to play the vision in the Avengers
and I went yes
so that's how that happened then how the
part you know came to me so like a Star
Wars I I got very lucky again it's Ron
Howard I heard Rahm was taking over the
movie I texted him saying hey run have
you ever spent long winter evenings
wondering why you're not in the Star
Wars franchise I have and he's sent me
back lol I'll get back to you and he did
and I thought I was gonna be a
stormtrooper or something you know just
cuz I wanted to say I was in Star Wars
because it was so important to me as a
kid and he may be the main bad guy in
Star Wars and like two weeks later I was
flying over to to shoot that was an
amazing experience for me because we're
in in 1977 I was six years old I went to
see Star Wars it was like when Dorothy
steps out of black-and-white into
Technicolor
in Wizard of Oz I was taken from this
sort of gray rainy miserable 1970s
London and transported to another galaxy
and I just thought I don't know what
that is but I want to be a part of it
and 40 years later Ron Howard made that
possible and so on so i'm he has saddled
me with a debt that I can never actually
repay him hey guys thanks for bothering
to listen to me talk about these
characters thank you
keep watching but not that closely
[Music]